For this first term, we'll have 5 divided by 5, which equals 1, we'll have a
cubed in the numerator and one b in the numerator as well. The second term would
be, 8a squared b, we'll have a squared in the numerator, and one b in the
numerator as well. For the third term, we'll have positive 3a, we'll have one a
left in the numerator, and b squared, divided by b squared, makes 1, so just
positive 3a for the third term. And finally, for the last term, we'll just have
negative 12, 60 divided by 5 equals 12, and the sign is negative, so we need to
make sure we include that here. Ab Squared divided by ab squared would just
equal 1, that's why we're only left with negative 12. This would be our answer
to our division problem.